family is looking for answers as to why
their dog died just a couple of days
after a grooming facility cared for him
our madison kimbrough spoke to this
heartbroken family this christmas day
she joins us live on the east side near
nellis and carey
madison the atencio family wants
justices they believe their dog connor
was severely mistreated right here at
paz sitter dog grooming and boarding
just last week the atencios picked up
their cocker spaniel kana from pazazz
sitter after being gone for eight days
on vacation owner scott atencio didn't
think anything of it since kana had
stayed there once before however when he
picked khanna up last week he knew
something was wrong kana seemed troubled
and wouldn't make eye contact and was
constantly shaking when the family
brought him back home his condition
worsened it was then that the family
noticed connor not only had bloody stool
and wouldn't eat but he had missing
teeth and bloody gums the atencios
booked a vet appointment for december
22nd just a couple days after picking
him up from the boarding facility but
that morning they found connor
unresponsive on the couch later passing
away not having him bark at me and jump
on me when i come through the door when
i come home from work you know having
you know my my youngest
youngest daughter
you know buy him a christmas present a
new new toy and everything
and
he's not even here scott immediately
went back to pizzazz to get answers and
they refused to help him or tell him
anything about connor's stay he took to
social media and it turns out there are
numerous reports from people about their
dogs being mistreated there at this
point the attentio family wants answers
and wants to make sure this doesn't
happen to anyone else
we reached out to paz for comment but
have not received a response we also see
that they have taken down their facebook
page we've also seen that through
volunteers they've said that the
conditions there were quote horrific and
unsafe reporting live from north las
vegas madison kimbrough live local now